hey everybody at its heart that pool -
is all about family true story my whole
life I'll be waiting for someone to say
hey she needs you
I let in cable get to him even in fact
the tea bag of the death fight for
what's right sometimes you have to fight
dirty
Hey
Deadpool here and this is what I look
like on a pathetic regular screen but
hold on to your balloon not because on
I'm at I look twice as what is this no
the screen is larger so naturally I'd be
larger - oh that great that that's just
great I'm a child actor now that always
ends well you see Deadpool in glorious
larger-than-life IMAX because bigger is
better
well that's precious
hey everybody its charlie we got some
new Deadpool to break down we finally
found out who Eddie Marsan is playing in
Deadpool 2 and we got some actual
dialogue from Julien Denison's Russell a
character if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos we're in the middle of
infinity war but Deadpool 2 is just
ramping up it's gonna get crazier and
crazier so the idea here is that he's at
this facility it looks like it's tied to
the purifiers because there's all these
references to purity human children are
the future there's a banner that says
purity on it it just seems like they're
going for purifiers but the thing is is
that Stryker is their leader they've
already done a bunch of different
versions of the Stryker character in the
x-men universe so I don't know if they
want to recycle that character so
whoever Eddie Marsan is playing it looks
like he's going to be a version of
someone from that storyline in the
comics now there is a Matthew Risman who
was the leader of the purifiers but what
I'm expecting them to do is just the
Ajax thing so Ajax in the comics is a
little bit different from Ajax in the
Deadpool movie little D powered more
human-like not quite as ridiculous
but I think if there's any hope for like
really crazy x-force Mutant Liberation
Front strife super sentinels Nimrod
master mode like the really nutty stuff
from the x-men Canon then the Deadpool
franchise is probably the place to
tackle that because you kind of go into
those movies knowing that they're gonna
be making fun of a lot of stuff so
you're already prepared for it to be a
little bit ridiculous and they tend to
package those mainstream x-men movies is
more straight-up drama like that's kind
of the way that they're selling Dark
Phoenix so it's a little harder to do
the more ridiculous stuff when you're
trying to sell it as a serious movie we
also get some more scenes of him
marshalling an early version of the team
it looks like Domino is really the first
person that he gets but I love the idea
that dopinder is now officially on the
team so he's here inside the inner
circle while they're meeting in blind
Al's apartment now it's a little unclear
what his relationship with blind al is
now because it seems like they're still
living together but it also kind of
seems like the trailer is telling us
that he's been living with Vanessa too
like maybe he who's hangs out a lot with
blind al because what he does is so
dangerous naturally people would come
after Vanessa again if they found out
who he was but like in that very first
trailer he comes back and says I'm sorry
I'm late I was trying to get rid of
all the gluten fired into space so it
does sound like that's his permanent
residence but the interesting thing here
is if we have Domino in this scene but
we don't have any of the other x-force
characters what might happen is is that
like he has this scene where he says
we're gonna form a super duper group
then he finds Domino she probably gets
some funny scene that explains why her
powers are valuable because Dibble
doesn't seem like he believes her
usually that's the setup for some funny
payoff where Deadpool tries to do
something to hurt and it backfires on
him big time so we'll see what that is
but it sounds like they have their team
up and then they slowly recruit the rest
of the team like it's not Deadpool
recruiting everybody and then them going
and doing all this other stuff just to
address the juggernaut theory this was
going around the internet and people
were pointing to some very particular
scenes like oh look this could be the
juggernaut there are two separate scenes
one with Colossus punching this giant
metal dome and then you see the giant
convoy truck just completely fly up in
the air like he's punching the convoy
truck there's a separate scene where
Domino is explaining her powers in that
funny montage during the trailer where
Deadpool's like that doesn't sound like
a thing you see her drop down into that
truck and you see a shot of the
dashboard there's a giant heat signature
on it like it's tracking some giant
person that looks as big as the
juggernaut but the thing is is I don't
think that's him it is totally possible
that they could invoke juggernaut or
make a lot of juggernaut jokes during
this because there was a similar scene
during x-men 3 where the juggernaut was
on the back of a truck I'm the
juggernaut [ __ ] prisoner must be
confined at all times if he builds any
momentum no object can stop him they
call you juggernaut
don't you know I am one of the most
parodied moments from that movie so that
would be ripe for Deadpool to make fun
of but I don't expect him to actually be
a character in this movie and I really
do think this is just Colossus on this
heat map and when he's punching this
metal dome
he's just punching something on that
truck so that the truck flies up in the
air but the other big theory that about
people were talking about was the Peter
wisdom Peter W theory because Peter has
this hilarious Twitter account that they
started to do viral marketing for the
movie his name is Peter W as in you
don't know what it is Peter wisdom is a
really powerful character from the
comics that just looks like a normal
person
totally mundane like an office worker
that you would run into like Ned
Flanders
Peter that you see in the movie here so
a lot of people are wondering now if
maybe this is sort of a misdirect like
he seems like a totally normal guy but
then at some point later in the movie he
manifests some crazy powerful ability
and it becomes a funny WTF moment but
usually in a serious movie somebody
manifest some big power and takes down
the villain you get this real big cheer
from the audience but the thing that
Deadpool does is it sort of parodies
moments like that so people then are
like wouldn't it be funny if Ned
Flanders here turned out to be the most
powerful character in this movie one
I'll say yes it's very likely that he is
the Peter Wisdom character giving him
the Peter W name doesn't feel like a
coincidence on that Twitter account but
the thing about his powers in the comics
is even though he's like crazy powerful
and he seems like a totally nice mundane
dude and when you read his tweets on his
Twitter account he's made to sound like
your lame dad like a Ned Flanders style
character but in the comics Peter wisdom
has been tied to Excalibur X force he
has the ability to summon electricity he
has this really crazy familial
relationship that ties to the occult and
a lot of crazy Excalibur comic book
related things so I'm not expecting a
lot of that to be incorporated in the
movie he might just have like this
totally normal facade and seem like a
totally normal dude but they might have
some hilarious backstory but do be
prepared for some big twist with his
character but let me know in the
comments do you actually think that he's
playing Peter wisdom and he's
have some crazy power that we'll see
during the movie and it just meant to
look really funny or do you think he's
just a totally normal dude and that's
supposed to be the joke the totally
normal guy your dad that joins x-force
they haven't said which of these x-force
members are gonna survive to the x-force
movie but I'm expecting pretty much
everybody with the exception of wildcard
Peter because we haven't got the full
explainer for his character yet in Bill
skarsgård like they're not gonna kill
off Terry Crews in obviously Domino
cable Colossus negasonic shatter star
like you can't kill shatter star off
after you build a month to be this super
cool dude with badass swords but that's
another good question for you which of
these X Force members do you think is
going to die during the film because it
would be weird if they didn't kill any
of them what's gonna happen tomorrow is
is they'll be more Marvel and once I do
start posting the spoilery infinity war
videos they will be marked clearly with
spoiler warnings just in case you're not
seeing the movie right away so no
worries it should be very clear which
videos are spoiler and which ones are
non spoilery but while you wait for
everything click here for my no spoiler
infinity war review and click here for
that last big Deadpool trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]